well she was a wonderful gal she was an
angel we we met and she she just loved
us and we loved her us that much your
love was absolutely gorgeous went to
little Hut's that were the home of the
munchkins and there was parade over on
the left of the stage and to the right
of the stage and all the munchkins lived
in there and that was a hundred and
thirty-five of us how about that
so Metro golden went to a lot of trouble
to get a lot of people to work for them
of course there we only got $50 a week
oh you know it's a Mervyn Leroy
production and you can't deny that it
was his clout that got this picture made
and at a cost of you know 2.7 million
3.2 million whatever it was all together
and but you look at the memos that
survived about what was going on from
day one even before Mervyn Leroy came to
Metro officially it was all Arthur freed
and Arthur freed then went on to do
babes and arms the same year with Mickey
and Judy George Cukor who was just about
to start Gone with the Wind was brought
in and he's the one who when Jack Haley
was coming in he implemented makeup
changes in the Wicked Witch the
Scarecrow and especially in Dorothy he
got the party dress off of her he got a
more natural look to her and told her
that the irony was and and he meant it
in terms of MGM in 1938 he said the
irony to Judy Garland is that you really
are Dorothy and the more real you are
the crazier this freak show around you
is going to seem you look at Judy
Garland's life and she was the girl from
the Midwest and her kind of tornadic
talent lifted her up and carried into a
crazy world of show business and
everybody went along on the ride that's
one reason oz is so resonant to this day
it's just part of all that well in the
integrated score idea was all Arthur
freed he wanted Jerome Kern at first and
Ira Gershwin a lot of different people
were up for the the songs but it fell to
Harold Arlen and Yip Harburg even if you
listen under the dialogue and you hear
the little bits of Night on Bald
Mountain and shade of the old apple tree
and we're aware has my little dog gone
and all these little echoes and when you
talk about as you did the fact that over
the rainbow was cut out of the film at
the second preview in Pomona it was in
in San Bernardino and they took the film
to Pomona and it's a legendary story
Yip and Harold are sitting there
watching The Wizard of Oz with great
pleasure for the second time and and
Aunt Em sister Dorothy find yourself a
place where you won't get into any
trouble and the next thing you see is
that that up that up that up that up and
three minutes a song out and not only
does that sir I think surprised us all
for a lot of reasons but you stop and
wonder what could they have been
thinking what would all of that
underscoring have meant for the whole
rest of the movie if you didn't have the
song to begin with so when the
preliminary budget for Wizard of Oz was
getting up to two million dollars and
you could make four big movies for two
million dollars in 1938 the money people
in New York Lowe's Incorporated who
controlled MGM from afar said in effect
you know Judy Garland is going to be a
star and and we were glad we have her
but can you get us some box-office
insurance can you get Shirley Temple
from 20th Century Fox and Louie B mayor
didn't especially like the idea and
Arthur freed and Mervyn Leroy didn't
like the idea at all but the great Roger
Eden's who was Arthur Fried's right-hand
musical man and who had already written
dear mr. gable for Judy and and was one
of her great champions was sent over to
Fox to listen to Shirley Temple sing in
person everybody had heard her in film
but he wanted to hear her voice you know
in the room as it were he came back and
was very praiseworthy of Shirley's charm
but he said her vocal limitations are
insurmountable in other words she can't
sing the way we want Dorothy to sing she
can't put it across I say this as a fan
but I also say it with as much
objectivity as I could muster because
somebody just recently asked me this
question they said well if Judy Garland
hadn't played Dorothy who else could
have played it as effectively and I said
well nobody then and nobody since then
and nobody now I don't know if you want
in either direction thank you I agree
with you the I think the the idea is
that you try to think of girls who sang
as well danced as well acted as well
could do the quiet humor that this calls
for could then be as charismatic as she
is at one reason this film I think
resonates no matter what generation were
in because certainly tastes in music and
entertainers have changed in 70 years
but not where this is concerned and a
big part of that is the fact that that
first scene when Judy's running up the
road with with little Terry the dog and
is worried about her pet it doesn't
matter if you're a little boy or a
little girl you get drawn into her
concern instantly she pulls you right in
and pulls you along through the whole
rest of the story there isn't a child
anywhere who can't identify with the
idea of possibly losing a pet or
definitely you know feeling nobody cares
at home nobody understands you think
about running away or you do run away
and then to compound it you're lost and
you can't get home and you're wondering
how to get home who else could have put
that across